his young adult fiction always told from
a first-person point of view that's
actually a great question
it is mostly most ye books that I see
are told from a first-person point of
view my books are not and actually do
you think that was a challenge and
selling them my books are written more
like Game of Thrones so written in third
person alternating point of views you
know but that said it is third-person
close so the third-person omniscient is
where more of like the gods perspective
third-person close is where you're still
in the character's point of view but I'm
writing it still in third person so I'm
actually hoping that we're gonna see
more of that because I think that it
gives more scope for the way you tell a
story especially in a genre like the big
science fiction types of stuff that I'm
writing
but yeah largely you see that and I
think part of that is that it is
relatable and that the voice of the
character then really shines through and
first-person stories can be great too I
mean the first book I ever wrote was in
first person and I haven't fully ruled
out ever writing in it again because I
think it can be fun and can be done
the downside of it and you can see it in
series like Hunger Games I love the
first book Hunger Games is told in a
first-person narrative but then and it's
a huge world but as the books proceeded
through the trilogy and you're still
locked into one point of view I started
to get very limiting by the third book
because we've had this whole revolution
going on you had all these districts and
yet you weren't able to see that in the
book whereas the film it was able to
open that up and show you everything
because the film you know has that
bigger perspective so I think it can get
limiting especially if you're looking at
telling a story over multiple volumes so
I'm hopeful that we'll see more
third-person narratives but yes you do
see a lot of the first person and second
person oh my gosh I had I had a writing
student it was like I'm writing in
second person and I was like are you
trying to make your life really hard I'm
not to say that it hasn't ever been done
or can't be done every rule can be
broken I think especially in a short
story or something more experimental you
could probably get away with it or pull
it off writing in second person through
the scope of a novel I think would be
extraordinarily to
part of the reason is that any always
tell my students this is that you know I
think it's worthwhile to always have
your reader in mind unless you just want
to write books in your bedroom and
nobody will read them and you're cool
with that but if you think you might
want readers you don't usually want to
do anything that's going to totally
throw them out of your narrative or lose
them and writing in second person can
feel I would think distracting just
because it's not typically done I mean I
don't even know that I can name a novel
that's written all in second person I
think you can maybe get away with it in
parts if you were trying to do something
interesting but you know you don't want
to do anything that's gonna really
disorient somebody now but I also always
say every rule has been broken will be
broken and there are incredible writers
who are gonna do things that I can't
even fathom so but I would say
especially when you're first starting to
write and don't do anything that's
reinventing the wheel or that's going to
make it too challenging for yourself
because it's already a huge challenge to
finish a novel it's like a huge deal so
I always recommend starting in first or
third person and a lot of times actually
in first person and the reason is that
developing voice is I think one of the
hardest things to do as a writer and it
is easier to do it in first person so
going back to the first story that you
wrote the first novel was that your
intention to have other readers or was
this more for you it was more personal
I've always written because I would love
to have readers I started writing
because I'm such a voracious reader and
they love nothing more than being caught
in the middle of a story where it's
keeping me up till 3:00 or 4:00 in the
morning because I can't put it down I
think it's a single best thing in the
world so I kind of wanted to write books
like that and wanted to write books that
where people would stay up late at night
reading them that's probably the biggest
compliment anyone could ever give me so
I started out thinking that I did want
to publish I did want to publish
traditionally ideally and I did want
other people to read my book that said
I'd wrote the first one in first person
because of the voice question like I was
trying to work very hard to develop
voice as a writer and like I meant
I think that's easier to do in first
person I had other reasons my narrator
is also unreliable that's another good
reason to write in first person if for
some reason you have a character that is
not trustworthy my character was an
alcoholic but she didn't know it and she
wouldn't admit it so it makes for an
interesting narrator the very popular
book girl on a train uses a similar
narrative technique right where the main
character has blackouts and doesn't
remember things so she is inherently
unreliable and it makes for a very good
thriller so um so that's another reason
to choose the narrator to be a certain
tense first person puts us in her POV so
we're beholden to what she thinks but
what if what she thinks is inaccurate
you